what would you say the results were
afterwards of black lives matter there's
a lot of Fallout from that would you say
it was good for relations across the
country everyone lives matter yeah in my
opinion so white people say look I think
all lives matter and they were called
racist or white supremacist if they said
exactly what you just said that's
ignorance that's ignorance but can you
see how that makes white people afraid
to even voice an opinion if you think
the system is rigged because it's racist
and I by the way I think the justice
system has a lot of problems and so
saying if we need to fix this system we
can't just approach it from a racial
angle all lives matter Justice matters
period then you can get the solution